doom eternal is an intense game and at
times you can be forgiven for feeling a
little overwhelmed by the demon horde
especially there are higher difficulties
so to make sure you're ripping and
tearing in the most efficient way
possible we've got a few tips to get
your slaying started the chainsaw works
a little differently in eternal than it
did in doom 2016 in fact it will become
essential in obtaining the valuable
ammunition you need to mulch enemies you
should be having that thing much more
than you did in the previous title as
now it will automatically charge to one
hip which is all that is needed to shred
apart basic imps and soldiers but you'll
still need to find fuel out in the world
if you want to buy sex larger enemies
like Cacodemons and revenants it took me
a little while to break the 2016 habit
of saving the chainsaw for larger foes
but in eternal you should be pleading
demons every damn opportunity
[Applause]
another way to get ammo if you're short
between arenas or want a few extra
shells and rockets before you leave an
area is to take advantage of the
exploding barrels around you not only
are they great to help ug of enemies
that wander too close to them
but with the right upgrades they can
also be a method of resupply using a
combination of the thicker skin
environment and generating barrels
upgrades means that not only did the big
red barrels drop munitions but they also
respawn and with immunity to their
blasts you can go around shooting and
punching them to your heart's content
until your pockets are brimming with
bullets
it took me a while to realize but both
your frag and ice grenades exist on
their own cooldowns so you can spam both
detonating carnage and freezing blasts
to your heart's content
this can be super useful in moments
where you freeze a bunch of demons to
give you some space only to blow them
apart with frags or to be sure you have
spares to stun any Cacodemons with a
shot to their mouth after a few upgrades
to you'll be able to fire them out
rapidly and get all the bonuses that
come with turning imps into ice cubes or
zombies into a thin red paste
through your playthrough you'll start to
find Sentinel crystals that can be used
to increase your health armor and
ammunition levels but if you link them
in the same skill tree you can get
powerful upgrades some of our favorite
combinations are loot magnet to bring
all those sweet drops to you and
combining quick-draw belch and belch
Armour boost to make the most of every
fiery shot you unleash from your
shoulders
it also means you'll get every armor
shard possible and since you're battling
through a demon infested earth you're
going to need them
rooms also offer valuable passive
upgrades as you come across them during
your crusade
now what room you use may rely a lot on
your playstyle but there's a few
standout ones I could heartily recommend
seek and destroy will allow you to
launch into a glory kill from further
away this is not only great to regain
health but it can grant some valuable
invincibility during the animation and
get you out of a sticky spot if you're
cornered punch and Reve means that you
can fire away with blood punch much more
safely and you're guaranteed to get a
good chunk of health back with each
meaty right hook dazed and confused
increases the enemy's stagger state
which may not seem that valuable but
later in the game where arenas can
really get hectic you'll be glad that
demon you didn't get a tear in half is
still kindly waiting for you to finish
it off personally I'm also a fan of
Chronos strike using your weapon mods in
midair will allow you to slow down time
which is great to assess the situation
you're shortly going to be landing into
or just for maximum cool points when you
land an in air slow-motion headshot on
whatever soldier is below you
you'll visit a1 through the story but
remember you can always go back to the
doom fortress prison if you want to warm
up try out a new weapon build or just
practice things like movement and weapon
switching without consequence all those
imps are locked up down there in the
bowels of your fortress so you may as
well use them for something
doom eternal comes with a whole host of
new movement options available to you
from the outset so be sure to utilize
them it's weird that it feels like I'm
barely on the ground or playing this
game but movement is key to staying
alive and eternal with all the enemies
firing rockets whipping energy blasts or
mobbing you and their numbers you can
get overwhelmed rather easily as badass
as the doom Slayer is he's far from
invincible so agility is the best
defense from fireballs and rocket blasts
so keep an eye out for things like
monkey bars and keep dashing as soon as
you're able to and don't be afraid to
use the super shotguns meat hook to drag
you out of the fray and towards that
lone enemy not all perks are created
equal and some will serve you much
better in the early game especially when
praise or tokens are harder to come by
thicker skin and frag stock ups will
allow you to shrug off barrel explosions
and fling your own munitions much more
frequently and getting item finder as
early as possible will make it much
easier to find future upgrades and
collectables - that is as long as you
keep one Slayer eye on your map it will
help you find more tokens as well as
Sentinel batteries which will then allow
you to unlock more tokens and items back
in your fortress
so there are a few tips to get you
started and do maternal if you have any
of your own be sure to leave them in the
comment section below and we may do a
follow up with even more hints to keep
you all ripping and tearing remember to
like the video and subscribe to GameSpot
for more doom eternal
[Music]